xenoblade chronicles 3 is the latest
game in monolith soft and tetsuyu
takashi's anthology xeno series what
that means is that similar to the final
fantasy series while the overall
gameplay and ideas are similar amongst
entries the story and characters are
completely fresh
so with that said what do we know about
xenoplay chronicles so far well here's
everything you need to know
xenoblade chronicles 3 is set in the
world of ionios which is notable for its
two major warring nations of kevis and
agnes every being from kevis and agnes
is raised to be a soldier and only has a
10 year life span which they refer to as
their 10 terms there's a mark on at
least one of the factions next that
indicates which term they're on the
ultimate honor for those born in nations
is to live out their full 10 terms and
then partake in a homecoming ceremony
given by their queen during which she
sends the soldier's spirits to the great
beyond
what the purpose of this is or what
happens to these characters after they
receive a homecoming ceremony is
something currently shrouded in mystery
since they're born fighting is all
members of these nations learn and know
as these nations exist in a state of
perpetual war while this is the base
your story focuses on six soldiers three
from kevis and three from agnes while on
a special mission these two enemies run
into each other and naturally end up
fighting until a mysterious figure leads
them on a quest to find sword march from
the 24 minute nintendo direct it sounds
like part of their goal will be to bring
peace to the two warring nations by
defeating the real enemy and restoring
world order to my understanding this
real enemy is called the consuls it
seems to me either these consoles or
other enemies if it's not the console
exist to eat the kevis and agnes for
their life energy during the nintendo
direct there was a line about certain
enemies not needing food or water to
survive but rather life itself
hence why i think this it could be that
the consoles or another enemy could be
pulling the strings to have the caves
and agnes kill each other for their life
energy but that's purely my speculation
and the reason for both the war and why
the consuls are presiding over it is a
mystery of the story we're also told
that the killing between the two nations
has to do with filling one's own flame
clock however what this flame clock is
or what makes it so important is
currently unknown the enemy specifically
says during a nintendo direct trailer to
our characters that if unchecked
oroboros will lead this world to ruin
therefore they must be erased notably as
i'll talk about in a bit our characters
can use the power of oroboros to bond
together and transform in battle so
perhaps this is another of the main
enemy's motivations so while the kevis
and agnes are constant war it seems like
there's a bigger enemy at play here and
similar to previous xenoblade chronicle
games probably some mysteries
surrounding your existence that will be
uncovered
we do see that through fighting together
for a common goal our main characters
come to befriend each other and come to
share a will to live in the now instead
of constantly fighting xenoblade
chronicles 3 is set in the massive world
of ionios ionios is filled with various
terrain and a multitude of enemies while
there is plenty to explore for the main
quest there are also many hidden areas
included for you to discover through
exploration every major location you
visit is saved as a landmark with quick
traveling available to it as soon as you
find it there are also quest routes you
can activate which will put a line on
the map showing you exactly what route
to follow for your current quest
some of the monsters in the world only
appear at specific times so xenoblade
chronicles 3 will also include the
ability to quickly change the time
however it's not clear if this is only
available in certain areas like response
or colonies or you can do this at any
point
colonies are the base camps for both
nations the colonies act as the game's
towns with stories dining options which
will give your party various temporary
stat boosts depending on what you eat
and various characters some of whom can
impart quests the game also seems to
have a character quest tree which
visually shows how these characters are
related to each other and by what quest
within the colonies are furonos which
are mobile bases and weapons of war
outside of colonies there are also rest
spots your characters can utilize here
you can cook using collected materials
cooking will give you various temporary
boosts just like dining within a colony
you can also craft gems here according
to the trailers it states to strengthen
your abilities by looking deeper into it
it looks like this is a crafting system
where you can craft various weapons
shields or other such useful in-battle
items and these crafted items will have
better effects than if you bought the
weapon you'll be able to discuss
information you heard from the various
residents you met at the colonies or
perhaps other places and choose to take
on their side quests here
the combat in xenoblade chronicles 3
takes place on the field and happens
once you encounter an enemy and draw
your weapon or they engage you you'll
control one character at a time while
duking it out with these enemies but for
the first time ever in a xenoblade
chronicles game you can switch which
character you control at any time each
of these party members has a role to
fill to ensure your victory with every
class essentially boiling down to
attacker defender and healer your
abilities are called arts and each of
these arts is assigned to a button on
the switch corresponding to the
on-screen visual making it easier to
execute and also know if an art is
available or not to use these arts have
a variety of effects that you'll have to
cleverly utilize during their best
moments during combat situations you can
also string together arts and perform a
combo of breaking down the enemy's guard
toppling them over launching them in the
air and smashing them back down there
may be other types of combos available
but we definitely know about this one
thanks to the latest overview trailer
similar to combos there are also chain
attacks you can sign your characters
each of the six main characters has a
specific class type although
interestingly you can actually change
each character's class as you please and
none of them are stuck to their original
class combining classes seems like it
will be an important mechanic in the
game as this will determine which arts
and general stats each character has
while also allowing you to find and
assign combos to your characters to form
your ideal party
some of the classes we know are sword
fighter zephyr medic gunner tactician
heavy guard ogre guardian commander
incursor and war medic the exp you get
from battles helps raise the class rank
of the current class you've selected for
each character allowing you to learn and
assign master arts these arts are unique
in that unlike the other arts that are
class specific you can assign master
arts to any class you choose for your
character meaning it will be key to
switch characters classes as you play
through the game in order to get them
various master arts you can gain allies
in the form of a seventh party member
while only one of these allies can help
at a time it seems like you'll
permanently gain these allies and be
able to swap them in and out to suit the
situation these allies called heroes
also have their own unique classes
separate from the main characters
once you befriend them you can even
reassign your main party members to have
these classes as well each of the main
characters has another character they'll
be able to interlink with this fuses the
two characters you choose together into
a mech-like form called an oroboros for
a limited set amount of time
these auroboros also have special arts
however not constrained by the same
limits as the characters on their own
each aura boros has two forms and the
form you see depends on which character
you have controlling the oroboros
both the appearance and moveset of the
auroboros alters depending on who you
have taking the lead for completing
battles you'll gain soul points which
you can use on a skill tree for your
oroboros to learn new arts and make them
stronger xenoblade chronicles 3 releases
july 29th 2022 with additional content
releasing later this year and into next
year through a xenoblade chronicles 3
expansion pass for an additional cost
and that's everything you need to know
about the upcoming xenoblade chronicles
3. are you a fan of this series or if
not excited to try a brand new rpg for
the switch let us know